I never would let me guess he's done  something crazy show me again I won't  break your neck well the Midwest  okay your brass gordon's Escorial that's  Lynch we moves Wow  I don't think Italy  motley I had a run-in with a space in  there  the rest of us focus on  that's the thing that killed my man  aliens  [ __ ]  predators exploit weakness tracks its  prey the game seems to enjoy it  it's not a predator that's a sports  hunter well we took a vote predators  cool it right [ __ ] yeah  ex- PTSD and then teen that's mental  you're insane right the launch  but fast and picking you up their idea  tourism  figured something out I think we're  gonna die  just pointing it out my big boys honor  he brought his dogs with me  the predator only in theaters September  14th  [Music]